Bronson's friends and supporters queued
early for a seat they were allowed to
watch the public parole hearing from a
London courtroom
the session itself was being held at
Bronson's prison 60 miles away but
distance didn't diminish the impact of
Bronson's often colorful evidence
describing his long life in prison he
said I've had more porridge than
Goldilocks than the Three Bears on his
violence I love a rumble what man
doesn't on his humiliating treatment if
I was a dog I'd have the rspca on my
side
on taking convicted plane hijackers
hostage in prison No Remorse I've no
compassion for terrorists after 11
prison hostages many assaults and
rooftop protests Bronson said he had
changed his ways he wanted to be freed
or at least moved to an open prison
ahead of the hearing Bronson sent Sky
News a postcard an ordinary London
Street Scene freedom to him
he urged the parole board to show
compassion at least for his aging mother
it's her lifelong dream he wrote to see
me free and happy
I think Charlie spoke from the heart you
know he didn't have any pretense I I
think he he came across as himself which
he would do and he put it out there to
to the panel as he as he wanted to you
know somebody who's reflecting back on
what he served over 48 years and now he
wants to look forward to to getting out
and seeing his mum you know and
associating back into society Bronson
was jailed in 1974 for armed robbery
repeated violent attacks on prison staff
and other inmates have kept him inside
virtually ever since most of his time is
spent in special secure units in a voice
message from jail last year he summed up
his despair
I've never murdered anyone I've ever
right to anyone what am I in jail for
the parole board has to decide if
Bronson needs to be kept locked up for
the safety of the public his prison
offender manager told the parole panel
he was making some progress in his
behavior
Bronson said he had been rehabilitated
through his art he had looked in the
mirror and told himself that's enough
pack it in
his supporters will be in court for a
second day this week to hear evidence
from psychologists and probation staff
Martin brunt Sky News